Democratic presidential candidate Bernie
Sanders is out of a Nevada hospital
after suffering a heart attack this week
hello everybody we are in Las Vegas I
just got out of the hospital a few hours
ago and I'm feeling so much better
the Vermont senator thanked supporters
in a video posted to Twitter he says
he'll be back on the campaign trail but
as ed O'Keefe reports Sanders health
scare underlines a shift in the race for
the Democratic nomination senator Bernie
Sanders emerged from a Las Vegas
hospital Friday three days after having
stents inserted to relieve chest pains
Sanders hadn't been seen since a private
fundraiser on Tuesday give me a chair up
here for a moment mrs. O'Neal the
doctors who treated him said in a
statement that Sanders was diagnosed
with a myocardial infarction another
term for heart attack they inserted two
stents in a blocked artery and all other
arteries were normal his wife Jane says
he'll head home to Vermont this weekend
to recover for the next democratic
debate on October 15th the health scare
comes at a turning point in the
Democratic race Sanders topped the field
for third quarter fundraising hauling in
more than 25 million dollars just ahead
of senator Elizabeth Warren former Vice
President Joe Biden raised 15 million
fourth behind mayor Pete Budaj
but it's Warren who is leading in some
national and early state polls as she
draws large and enthusiastic crowds
including 8,500 people Thursday night in
San Diego the doctors who treated
senator Sanders this past week in Las
Vegas say they anticipate good expected
progress he's a life long road runner
who until this week had a clean bill of
health and at the age of 78 Sanders is
the oldest Democrat running for
president for CBS this morning Saturday
at O'Keeffe Washington